foreign
let's go out to Detroit and talk to B
what is up B
hi John how's it going ah dude
incredible how are you oh good just
wonderful
just wonderful good great grand
PA good I'm glad you did wonderful
what's up how can I help
um okay so I just started dating this
awesome guy
um we've almost been dating for like
five months
to his career and getting it going he's
um and recently he was away on a
business trip for about two weeks and he
told me that he might in the future on
the future business trip have to take
girls out to dinner
um to secure business deals
and I was like I don't like that so so I
guess my question is is it is it normal
for this kind of thing to happen in the
business world if you're in sales to
like take I mean I might I know men like
take other men out to dinner to like
secure sales and stuff and like buy them
dinner but I didn't know that like guys
took girls out too so
yeah it's it's
there's a whole host of things here I'm
interested what was his response when
you said hey that makes me uncomfortable
um
I he said it was strictly about business
um and he didn't understand that I was
upset
um he said that he felt like it was a
trust thing and I needed to trust him
um and he said he thought that I was
being overly dramatic and like bringing
insecurity baggage into a relationship
um
so yeah
all right lots of things here
give me one or two direct questions
because there's a lot going on here
he doesn't understand why I'm upset for
him taking like a girl
from his like
um customer like one of the places he's
at one of the customers that's a girl
taking her out like a she's a client to
dinner and like buying her dinner and
that's just them to one-on-one yeah so
um to answer your question yes it is
common happens all the time colleagues
go out and you're not crazy
not even a tiny little bit
okay so I did
um I did I did this all the time in my
former life when I was in academics but
it was with
um academic colleagues
and 100 of the time
I texted my wife and let her know and I
texted my wife when it was over
not ever going to cheat on my wife but
man it was important for I didn't ever
want someone to come up to her and be
like hey I saw John was so and so I saw
him with this woman at lunch today so
that's what I'm worried about well hold
on so number one there was always that
level of communication there was never
any any and that was me trying to honor
my wife okay and there's just there was
a reality to the business I was in
and
it made for problems
I ended up really really liking spending
time with people
that were not my wife I craved there
laughing at my jokes I craved them
wanting to hang it right so it was not
smart on my part
and so I think it's wise
oh and also let me just say this we live
in a world unfortunately where
there's
um there's been a shift in guilty until
proven innocent
so if somebody walks away from some of
these exchanges and just says hey this
person offered me this said this it can
create some mess and so I I now I just I
just always have somebody with me that's
just that's just a personal thing on my
end and I know I can get grief like that
I'm not being Equitable and I'm treating
people differently I'm trying to be wise
for me for my wife for my family for my
business wisdom globally
and I've never ever had a what I would
call a sales experience or a client
interaction
that wasn't bolstered by having somebody
else in the room yeah I've just never
had that so that's number one
and number two it does cause problems
here's the bigger issue for me
I know I have friends of mine dear
friends close great friends that are
women
that wouldn't care one like two days
from Sunday if their husband was out
doing sales calls a woman wouldn't even
wouldn't even think about it yeah what
do you enter their mind and I've got
friends who are like you makes them very
uncomfortable that my husband's gone for
two weeks or my boyfriend's gone for two
weeks in four states over and every
night of the week he's with the same or
one or two women like that they feel
uncomfortable by that here's my concern
for your relationship right now
that at the res after receiving how you
feel about something
the guy that you started this call by
saying he's an awesome guy he's so great
and so wonderful
immediately made you stupid for having a
Feeling
and I don't like that at all
you're allowed to have your feelings and
if it makes you uncomfortable
then as somebody who honors you and
wants to be with you for a long time and
treat you with dignity and respect he is
going to look at his environment and see
if there are ways that he can honor the
person he's saying he loves
see what I'm saying yeah that makes
sense and so I don't like whether it's
right or wrong I I have the way I choose
to do it now that's just me I also
um I'm not gonna beat anybody else up
you're gonna make your own decisions I
think I've
put myself in situations that weren't
wise and it's just I I I have some
pretty clear boundaries now so be it
yeah
what I'm more concerned with your
relationship is you said hey I'm
uncomfortable with this hey I don't like
this and he said you're stupid
and B you're not
yeah can I ask you a harder question
okay you have other trust issues in this
relationship no
um yeah yeah exactly what are they where
does it where does it come from
I heard one of his good friends
um they were friends with benefits like
a couple months before we started dating
and she keeps
asking him to hang out and she asked him
to like move in for the week in July and
he didn't like immediately say no to her
he was in the I didn't know if he was
like gonna really tell me about it I
just kind of saw the text come up on his
iPad while we were watching a show
together
um I don't think he would ever do
anything he's never given me a reason
not to trust him but it's just her being
he just goes out with other women on on
work trips
uh this isn't like a work trip friend
it's like one of his friends no I know
you just said he never gives me reasons
to not trust him except the whole reason
you called me is because you're having
trust concerns yeah so I I I I I you
called and so um I am
not inserting myself into this
conversation I I'm I I just want to be
super clear I think there's other things
going on in this relationship
uh and I I have no only thing I have to
base that on is a couple of data points
and maybe I talked to him and he was
just like a lug head who's just like oh
what
um y'all are five you're five months in
and it feels like he's got one foot in
and he has still got another foot out of
the boat that's how I
okay oh
not a little bit you've been feeling it
a lot and for some reason you minimize
your feelings has that been happening to
do your whole life that people you say I
feel this way and people say you're
stupid
do you overreact
I think I do
I I mean I usually have to ask people if
I'm overreacting okay
um because I'm not really sure okay so I
want you to get two or three women in
your life that you trust deeply
yeah and if you feel your heart beating
faster or you feel that burn inside your
chest I want you to reach out to one of
them and you know why because I do this
because I'm overreact to things I get
extra mad or extra my feelings hurt so I
want you to have a couple people in your
pocket that you can ask as you are
learning your own body but let me tell
you this
somebody told you a long time ago to
stop listening to B
and I want you to never do that again I
want you to listen to what your body's
trying to tell you
and if you've been dating a guy for five
months and he's the best guy in the
whole world but he's also still keeping
up with
an old girlfriend that he used to hook
up with regularly or old friend that he
took up with regularly just a few months
before y'all were together and he's
taking women out and not that he's doing
business and trying to do sales
but that he makes you feel stupid he
tries to turn the whole thing back on
you I don't know why you don't trust me
what's the deal he turns it all back on
you without saying yeah I can see that
I think you should trust your gut
something does not feel right if he
wants to call me I'd be happy to talk to
him not like you know yeah bro not that
kind of way but
something doesn't feel right
something doesn't feel right and at some
point soon I think you need to have a
very come to be conversation
and put is there infidelity in this
relationship on the table is there um
gas lighting going on in this
relationship
here is what I feel be very very very
clear about what I feel and more
importantly what I need
and if he can't provide that 40 cool he
may not be the guy for you in fact he
won't be the guy for you
this isn't a this isn't a call about
um
sales calls between men and women that's
not that's not the call the call is you
have a guy
that you love who has said he loves you
and these 100 dismissive of how you are
experiencing your relationship with him
that's the red flag